索性吧，不知道是背后还是怎么回事，不知道我们现在到底是为了孩子呢，还是为了为了孩子这个婚姻啊，到底要不要继续下去，说说你老公是啥情况啊？
我的情况呢，是这样子的，我们结婚呢9年了，嗯，女儿今年7岁，我跟我老公两个在生日上面呢，嗯，有点悬殊，我一年大概在30~40左右，然后我是手艺人嘛，做美业的手艺人，然后我老公呢，嗯，结婚这十年当中吧，反正感觉也没闲着，但是吧，反正也挣不到什么钱，然后呢。
就这两年呢，在网上开了一个什么小电商的店，其实他经济这一块我没有过多的去顾问，因为平时工作比较忙，我只能说把孩子这一块做好，然后呢，其他他经济这块他也从来没有说把钱给到我手上，说这多少钱一年上交多少钱，从来没有过的，这10年当中，家里的开销呢，请假吃饭这一块呢，是我公公在帮我们搞，然后一直的工作没有做过。
然后我主要负责小孩子的教培啊，就课外教培这一块，他呢就是我感感觉这这么东理的强化，就这一点就是我不太能接受，然后从两年前吧，我就开始计划，那么我就想啊，你看我们自己这辈子80后啊，我是八六的，他是八五的，我说咱俩这辈子都碌碌无为，就是在社会上工作啊，感觉蛮辛苦挺累的啊，我说那个我有我身边有朋友，就是带着小孩子去欧洲啊，也有去家国啊，美国啊China样的这些小国家，说咱们普通的家庭可以找一个小一点的欧洲国家，那么想让孩子去接受不一样的一个教育，想让孩子多铺一条路啊，这样子，因为咱们毕竟是普通家庭啊，我说咱俩这个，咱今年都是学渣，他是普通的大专，我呢大专都没上，是一个函授的，高中毕业做了一个函授大专啊，那么我就傻跟的讲，嗯，每天做他工作他也不听，我老公是属于那种，就是所有人看起来他的老好人，老好人，你找他吵架，找他说话，你跟他撕心裂肺的喊，他都不会睬礼，就是说情绪超级稳定，他有的是说，我说哎呀，你都快40岁的人了，已经幼稚啦，冲动啊，这样子，这样子，其实我觉得我的内心并不冲动，因为我我就跟他说，我说我这如果冲动，嗯，我说我们这个家庭像是我的结果拿的比你要多一点。
啊，我说我呢，我我身边的人也是这样子的，我肯定想上有结果的人去学习啊，我说你看你办才结婚十年了，你都没有拿到什么结果回来，包括现在银行还欠个20个W，就是他搞一个小买卖嘛，还是去5W都没有钱的，我说这样不钱的，后来我就说，我说我也不要给挣钱了哦，我说呢，我们就往这条路上面走，把孩子带出去，你要是负责把我孩子教育好，非养好，我说我能在国内我挣点钱给你寄生活费，一年30个W，我借给你，但前期出去呢，可能付100多个W这个费用，我说因为我婚前，我结婚的时候，我存款是有100个W的，这些都是我婚前自己挣的嘛，但我没有告诉他，他不晓得我这我有这个钱嘛，我是在婚前自己买了一套房子啊，一七年就结婚。
17年的时候，17年买了一套房子，19年的时候分别买了一套房子，等于是婚后买了两套房子，但是呢，挂在我妈妈的名下，没有挂在我自己的名下，嗯，一套按揭不过是一次性，我们现在也不理想，我就说我不动你们家的气，我把我自己的房子啊，包括我现有的我10个W啊，我全部都堆到一起，把孩子送出去，我说你就把孩子带好。
就这样子，我说回以社为的孩子，他对我来了一句，说难道我的后半生的只是为了孩子吗？我说对呀，我说咱俩这辈子碌碌无为，这辈子就是为了小孩啊，我连话分都不敢生，我就想请了这一个孩子，如果我生二胎的话，家里更本就培养不出什么优秀的孩子啊，小方生活都会都做不到嘛，就跟他无法沟通，哎呀，就经常啊，冷战啊，你跟他吵了不跟你吵。我说我对，好像对这个空气讲话一样。
突然感觉就一点不了解他，来，姑娘，我问问个实际的问题好不好？
就是你和你老公的语言能力怎么样啊，你和你老公现在掌握的这个外语的这个水平，足不足以支撑他在国外能够正常的生活呀。
他个人能力肯定不行啊，但是我觉得他是有学习能力的，因为婚后之后呢，那段时间呢，他没有什么正儿八经的工作，我说那你就考一个那个叫不是蛮多考一个一建二建那个证嘛，嗯，每天也是看书啊，死记硬背啊，我说你就是那个学点考个证嘛，好像也是那挂书的那种，他也考出来了，他有两年时间嘛，也考出，他是对我有学习能力的，因为我平时工作比较忙，没有什么时间去学习。
嗯，其实你的这个故事里面啊，嗯，实话实说，我反而能够供起你的老公，因为让我想象一下，在三四十岁的年纪，语言能力又不行，又没有什么出国游学的经历，没有什么一个人在国外生活过的这个阅历，你让我带着孩子去出国，从零开始我也会恐惧的，我也会觉得无所适从的，除非是什么，除非是你在国外打下了基础，比如你，你什么都已经弄好了，什么房子租好了，工作各方面都已经顺利了，且能挣到钱了，我的孩子跟着你出去，对吧，我们就有一个安身立命的地方啊，就能够在你的基础之上能够正常的生活了，或许对于我来说还是一种啊，就是就这样的吸引力，对吧？你让我看到了你在那里活的很好，你让我看到了你在那里挣钱也很健康，现情就很健康，让我感受到了你能够给这个家庭带入一个新的台阶，我才有可能动这个心。但是你现在直接要求我先，对吧，什么都没有，什么什么前路都是完全看不到的情况下，你要求我带着孩子，我先出去。
我做不到，真做不到，真的换位思考，哎。
你，你对吧，三四十岁的一个男的了，他在国外举目无亲，什么都没有，生存的资本都没有，你让他带着孩子出去，你不逼死他吗？国外这一块吧，因为我身边呢，也有小姐妹，她们就是跟我们家情况差不多，然后也就是在那边，现在已经是等于安定下来了吧，然后考虑到亲戚这一块呢，两家差不多，嗯，我觉得应该是可以的，你要不，你要是说你有一颗对吧向上拼搏的心，这件事情本身啊是好事，你有一颗想要改变自己的阶层，想要活出另一番天地的这个念头，这是一个好事儿，但是你这个步骤是不对的，不应该先逼着他们出去，你要是有这个本事的话，你先出去，你先支个摊儿，你先把这个路都打通了，先掏一遍。
想过，我想和你，但我一旦出现了我，我在国内这个收入就断了呀，没办法指望他一年给我生活费啊，一旦出去，这个你就断了，我一个人在国内赚了个你，哼，我仅供参考啊，我也没有办法改变你的这个意愿，但是我只是摸着良心说，在你的故事里面，其实我更能共情的是你老公这个角色，因为他也没有安全感。说实话啊，两口子之间的关系是比较脆弱的，如果他把国内的所有东西都抛弃了，工作也抛弃了，什么都抛弃了，他带着孩子跑出去，哎，结果你俩关系都不好了，那人家在外头怎么办？
怎么活是不是啊，就是你的这个要求啊，你要求你的老公放弃现在的一切，带着孩子去欧洲，你这个要求本身是强人所难的啊，姐妹。
这个确实是一点强人阻拦，我就想着嘛，一切为了小孩子，因为他目前在国内确实做这个事情呢，也看不到什么未来，其实有个三五年呢也不行，因为他性格是非常非常内向的，做销售他也不行，这个人是非常好的人，老好人，对孩子也是一个非常好的父亲，但是我跟他爸在情感上面呢，就没有什么沟通的。
就是这种感觉，因为家里的主要经济是我在扛着大头，然后呢他呢可能就是辅导小孩子学习作业这一块呢，付出的比较多一点。
所以我说那与其这样子的话，反正你在工作这一块呢，也没有什么大的对吧，收获及成趣，我说那你干脆就一心搞孩来就好了呀。
姐妹，这是站在你的立场上来对别人的人生去指手划脚的，你要知道啊，哎呀，每个人都是要追求自己的安全感的。
除非说我我我我就这么说吧，把你当成一个男人，把他当成一个女人，这个关系就是你们两口子现在的关系，如果把你当成一个男人，你要求一个女人说辞职带孩子出去读书好，我问你，你拿什么给人家保障，比如说你上来给她100万，让她踏踏实实拿着这个钱出去，让她有一个安全感，还是你上来给她多少钱？
如果说你不给对方任何安全的保障，却提出一个让对方放弃自己生存的饭碗的要求的时候，无论男女，这都是强人所难，给了你，给他一百一百二十个搭配了。
你给了120个现金啊。
我去给他120个，然后每年再给30个。
因为是前两年我不过去，我说你过去啊，把一些安顿好了，前期啊学学语言，考考驾照，然后后面呢，我把国内安利好了，我也会过去跟你们就是碰头汇合，咱们不是说非得在国外生老病死的，我说孩子上大学了，咱俩他回来啊，就是这种安慰，他就是不亲的无感，说这种他在在这之前呢，我们两个也闹过离婚啊，就是说嗯，爱情哈，我们就想跟年夫妻啊，花火过日子的合作伙伴，那种感觉，我感觉没有多爱，可能是更多的就是对己家庭对孩子一种责任了，就这种感觉，那你希望王菲姐帮你干点啥呀，我现在就是在想要不要离婚，还是对我自己带着算了吧，如果非我自己在的话，我妈妈这边呢。
他可以帮我带孩子，他跟孩子感情好吗？很好。
很好，那你你因为这个事儿跟人家分手的话，对孩子来说是不公平的呀，那明白他也是孩子，爸爸可以随身看你呀，哎哟，你以为我听不出来你这意思吗？你这意思跟他离婚了之后，将来你就带着孩子就出去了，你还给人看，那可以找我的呀。
他如果找孩子愿意妥协的话，我还是给他留一条，对对的，你是是你，其实说白了，你想用离婚这种方式逼你的老公妥协，逼你的老公想孩子了，跑到欧洲去看你们，就这个意思，不过屏幕前打我的啊，很难听啊，我们这个人啊，不是恋爱了，不是说有人啊，想换人了，没有这个想法，我的脑子里面不是恋爱了，从来不是说要换男人，没有这个想法。
因为这个我我不能认同你的做法啊，反正我我觉得。
如果你要真有这个本事，你自己先去干一番事业，你自己先去站稳了脚跟，能证明你在那个地方活得很好，并且能够让他们都活得很好才行。你不能先要求人家去牺牲现在的一切，去一个异国他乡。
好吧。
这个我一的话，我广播我跟他说，我说咱俩换个角色，我可以带孩子出去学习啊干嘛的，我也可以，但我从头开始到异国他乡去带着孩子学习干嘛，如果你在国内，你能给予我一切就是送礼啊，给我保证一个最基本的生活质量也OK，但这体他不可能这后呢一圈，最后我要是搞完一个比较好的状态，那到时候可能是我的心态就变了，我不赞成你离婚这个事儿，也不赞成你逼你老公先出去这个事儿，我我我觉得你就应该换位思考一下，嗯，目前的话，如果说我不自己不真婚的话，在国内过的是非常安稳的，就是有这个想法之后呢，就是比较内后。
你可以抽抽个时间，你去你那个小姐妹，那你去看看他们的生活状态嘛，是吧，给自己放个假嘛。
到这，嗯，咱俩就聊到这儿啊，我我跟大家伙说一下啊，虽然说嗯，大家在我这儿花了钱来跟我连麦都是希望好像得到龙飞的一种心理支撑啊，希望我给大家得到一种心理的力量，但是有很多事情，嗯，就是虽然说大家都是我的粉丝，都是我的姐妹，但是也不是说所有的事情我我都能够认可，都能够支持啊，就像刚才这个姐，其实我真心的能共情这个父亲，他可能就是自己没有什么赚钱的能力，自己没有什么赚钱的能力的人，嗯，内心其实是比较没有安全感的，我这么说不过分吧，我直播间有男有女啊，你们看认不认同这个观点，就是自己本身没有什么赚钱能力的人，他是没有什么安全感的，没有什么安全感的人，你还要求他是吧，先去闯荡，你看要求他先去一个语言也不通什么连，连坐的公交车都不会，连租房子都不会，连买机票都不会的，这么一个情况下，你要求他一个人就带着孩子就去闯荡了，你不逼死他吗？我给他举一个例子。
我记得有一次我给我爸妈买了机票，帮他们飞到北京来，我爸妈是从来没有坐过飞机的，然后呢，就是到了机场之后，也不知道该怎么换登机台，也不知道该怎么呃托运行李，也不知道该怎么怎么做，然后又张老师那个飞机又晚点了，一晚点的话，晚点了大概5个小时，6个小时，然后我爸就开始就要发脾气了，为什么呢？就是因为他对于陌生的环境啊，那些机器，那些什么自动打印的那些机器，那些选什么座位的那些程序他不了解，他不了解的话，他就会有一种天然的抵触感，我其实能理解我的爸爸发脾气这个事情，那同样的道理啊，就把这个事儿换到刚才连麦的这个姐妹，她老公身上，语言又不通是吧，自己又没有什么经济基础，又没有什么赚钱的能力，你说你自己要有经济基础，有赚钱的能力的话，我可以请个翻译啊，那我可以吧，一一个月花多少钱，我可以请个翻译，到哪都行啊，但如果说自己经济基础又不行。
语言又不通，又还带着个孩子，你想象一下他去异国他乡，他是一种多么难的天崩开局啊，反正让我想的话，我是不敢的，就语言又不通对吧，又没有什么钱，又带着一个孩子去到别的地方，那我不行，真不行，所以就是就是刚才这个姐妹，你不要想的那么简单啊，你不要把这个事情想的如此的简单。